For example, when you played this part...
...in "Memoirs of a Teenage Amnesiac",...
...did it add something to your understanding?
The requisite PR cut.
Yeah.
Did it add something to your understanding of yourself?
Or was this an interesting new life for you to try?
Absolutely, 'cause I'm not a tennis-playing jock.
And so I thought, it was fun to do that and to be this guy,...
...and he just doesn't care at all.
You don't pressure your girlfriends to have sex with you after?
Why do I have to need to pressure?
Yeah, you're getting pressured It goes the other way around.
Yeah. Yeah. That's right!
I'm too tired, I am sorry.
Again?
Yeah.
No. Yeah. Yeah. I think it was great.
I mean, I especially like the character and also...
...being out here again working with Ken'ichi and Maki,...
...Maki, most obviously.
But I got to know Ken'ichi as well in here...
There they are.
There you go.
The requisite PR shot.
In case you don't know who I'm talking about.
In case you're not sure which movie we're talking about.
We're talking about this film.